&gt;&gt; Sometimes the equation isn't as easy to work with. Here this isn't in slope
intercept form. I don't have y equals mx plus b. This one's actually in standard
form. So we want to change it into slope intercept form so we can more easily
graph it. If we don't want to create a table to graph this equation, then we can
convert it to slope intercept form. If I subtract x from both sides I get
negative 2 y equals 4 minus x. Im going to rearrange these terms so the x term
comes first. So I have negative x first and then positive 4 right after it.
Finally, to solve for y, we divide each term by negative 2, this isolates y.
Remember this is a negative 1 as the coefficient in front of x. When we simplify
this we have positive 1 half x minus 2, 4 divided by negative 2 makes negative
2. Here's an equation we're familiar with. There's our y intercepts, our b, and
there's our slope, our m 1/2. We can just graph this like before.